hey guys this is gonna be a product
review of teaching the hand it's gonna
be a brutally honest review it's not a
sponsored video they did send the
products out to me but it didn't ask me
to make a video or anything so I am
gonna make a product review because I
know some of you guys have asked me
about it but before I say anything I'm
gonna do a 30 day test and then try to
use their product for 30 days we're
gonna look at before photos and also the
octave photos or videos so there's no
waste any more time let's get right into
the video I have a dream that's all I
need I'll make it up there was so much
Emily
[Music]
I'm gonna test it up I'm gonna take a
month test up these products and then
you're gonna see is my skin gonna look
better it's gonna look this same or is
it gonna look worse now this is how I
look like right now I've been using PC
for men sometimes Clinique and sometimes
some other products that's really really
good so we can see how teaching Hanley
is gonna change my face
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
all right it's been one month and this
is what my face looks like right now all
right it's not really better and it's
not really worse which is actually great
you know because it shows that teach
Hanley can actually compete with the
best skin care products that I use but I
have to be honest and tell you what I
realized when I use their products first
of all let me show you this it's really
affordable right but the containers are
really small let me show you an example
all right this guy the am warning facial
moisturizer got only 22 milliliters
right when you look at some of the other
products from TG Handley you see that
he's basically the same the PM got the
same amount the PM bedtime facial
moisturizer which has 22 milliliters and
actually the super serum here got less
got 15 which is interesting because
you're gonna use this guy more than the
moisturizers because the a.m. you're
only gonna use in the morning the PM
oyster are you only gonna use an evening
but the super serum you're gonna use
that in the morning and the evening
which is strange that I think this
should be a lot more anyway
the facial wash is good at 75
milliliters so that's great and then you
look at the scrub and the scrub is the
same 32 milliliters but you only use
this twice a week so it's okay to not be
that much but let's compare that for
example with PC for men if you look at
PC for men he's got 60 milliliters
that's almost three times as much you
know and then when you compare the PC
for men with Clinique for example to
make how much does this have 125
milliliters so this is twice as much as
piss for men which is yeah so you guys
need to look at not only the price but
how much does the bottles contain it's
very important so that's the first thing
I realized another thing I realized is
well it says here in the directions
after washing your face massage your
pea-sized amount into your entire face
and
pea size that is pea size that's very
small now my skin type is dried to
normal skin and I've been using this
here winter in Japan and on my skin is
even more dry right because of winter
and so I felt that it's not enough
I didn't even complete the whole 30 days
because now my a.m. and the PM is
already finished I think on day 23 24 it
was already finished so yeah no a
pea-sized especially if you want to add
some on your neck because that's what
they say right your whole face and
entire neck the pea size I feel
personally is not enough the other thing
I realized is the scrub as soon as I
added some of the scrub on my face it
started to give me this burning
sensation which I really did not like so
I feel like it's not really that good
for sensitive skin all right now
honestly I believe it would be better if
teacher Han Lee had products
specifically for dry skins and
specifically for oily skin but I also
understand why they don't because they
want to have skin care that's
uncomplicated they don't want to have
too many skin care products and make it
too confusing so that is their strong
point but it's also their weak point
because then the guys with very dry skin
like myself or guys who have oily skin
they're gonna feel like hmm these
products are not quite right for me so
apart from those issues yes TJ only
impressed me because number one my skin
still looks great number two their stuff
is uncomplicated or you know so it's
easy for most guys out there will it
help you to have better looking skin
well yeah I think so depending on your
skin type especially if you're in the
middle if you have very dry skin if you
have very oily skin then maybe not but
if you're somewhere in the middle then
yes right so would I keep on using TJ
honey well no because I think this for
me my specific skin type I love to use
PC for men because I feel like it helps
me more any and it helps my skin in the
way that I wanted to for example I'm out
in the Sun all the time mostly on
modeling and castings in exploring new
countries right so one of the
differences hold on a second so here we
go so this is the daytime protect which
is today moisturizer and this is the am
morning facial moisturizer from teach
Hannah so both of them are like or did
they time moisturizer so this guy from
TJ Hanlon got 20 SPF while from PC for
men he's got 30 there's a lot more other
reasons why I'm gonna keep on using PC
for men and some other products that I
believe in and that really worked for my
skin type so no I'm not gonna use teach
Hanley but I think for some of you it
might be a really good option so I'm
gonna either link for you to get a
description so you can check them out
and also do your own research I'm also
gonna add for you the products that I
personally use and that I believe in and
then I'm also gonna give you a few extra
options of quality products that you can
look into now if you like this video
wait before you go before you go if you
want to know a few more tips on how to
get healthy and clear skin check out
this video is really gonna help you out
and now if you like this video give it a
thumbs up subscribe and we will talk
soon Cheers